on va rester en californie vous savez
que le gouverneur arnold schwarzenegger
a été l'un des premiers élus américains
à s'engager en faveur de l'environnement
à los angeles la prise de conscience des
citoyens n'en est encore qu'à ses débuts
mais certains ont décidé de se passer de
voiture définitivement le reportage de
carine azzopardi et denis bassompierre
los angeles la ville les autoroutes des
échangeurs et du smog ce nuage de
dioxyde de soufre et d'autres produits
toxiques causés par la pollution
automobile
impossible dans cette mégapole
d'échapper à la voiture et pourtant
certains ont décidé de faire autrement
sommer roule uniquement à vélo il faut
juste faire gaffe aux gens qui dorment
au volant qui sont dans la lune il est
électricien dans les studios d'hollywood
et limite ses déplacements à 10
kilomètres autour de son domicile
il ne pollue pas et en plus ça lui fait
gagner de l'argent tu as un vélo à la
place d'un camion ton assurance l'épée
laissant ce que tu as pas à payer ça
réduit ses dépenses
quand on se compare avec mes concurrents
qui ont un véhicule gît yann sommer vie
avec des gens qui partagent sa vision
des choses dans un éco village
ici les habitants ont une ligne de
conduite
chaque geste chaque décision doit
respecter l'environnement
aujourd'hui ces visites guidées tous les
matériaux de semur ont été produits
localement
oui super les 40 personnes de l'immeuble
n'utilise jamais de voiture
leur rêve reconquérir l'espace
automobile
ah non moi je sais que vous avez envie
de laisser passer cette voiture mais
elle va trouver quoi faire alors venez
comme ça dans le cercle
c'est important que les automobilistes
trouvent tout seul ce qu'il faut faire
on appelle ça de la rééducation
automobile quand ils font le tour c'est
après faut bien lire merci merci merci
chaque dimanche repas bio tous en commun
pour eux les nouvelles technologies ne
sont pas la solution face au
réchauffement climatique
ce qui me dérange par rapport à ça c'est
que les gens pensent qu'ils peuvent
continuer à faire comme ils ont toujours
fait ils se disent je vois pas pourquoi
je changerais quelqu'un va trouver une
technologie pour nous sauver
ici dans cette communauté on pense qu'il
ne suffira pas à s'adapter
il va falloir changer radicalement notre
mode de vie
ce genre de communauté est ultra
minoritaire aux états unis vient peu
d'américains sont disposés à abandonner
leur confort